welcome to another episode of the
award-winning podcast not too deep I'm
your host grace Helbig we have one of
the Fab five with us today
it's Bobbie Burke I'm thrilled he was so
cool and wonderful and gives us direct
and aggressive pointers on what not to
put in your house and how to decorate
and his whole life story is just so
fascinating and he's really cool and he
dresses really well and he smelled
amazing I know you won't be able to hear
that orab see it but just trust that
that was there in the room the whole
time I'm not gonna keep rambling enjoy
this episode of not too deep with Bobbie
Berg deep is sponsored by the podcast
terrible thanks for asking in each
episode host Nora mccurdy talks to
regular people about their experiences
with you guessed it terrible things the
Atlantic has named terrible thanks for
asking one of the best podcasts of 2018
and the New York Times calls it a gift
to listen you can find terrible thanks
for asking wherever you listen to
podcasts I always sound so much deeper I
feel like he's mine yeah I feel like I
sound like I have more gravitas than I
actually like do you feel like Frasier
tossed salad and scrambled eggs
remember the William makin episode in
season 2 where he was like his fashion
icon his Frasier Crane may be your yeah
but not fashion no no no even link
I think his suits were purposely
ill-fitting on the show it was awesome
the 90s I think suits were just right
when pleated pants weren't ironic when
they were genuine often are they is that
for real
yeah no way Tan's wearing them I mean if
tans wearing in their back I feel like
he's doing a long con a big prank on
everyone because you have no idea
i pleated pants just look like two
foofa's on your upper thighs and I don't
I can't get on board with that remember
the show mr. Cooper never fails yeah
every time someone says Fupa you have a
great singing voice thank you um I think
we've begun I think that's absolutely
correct ready to begin with Bobby berry
Karen not too deep thank you for being
here I appreciate it you guys travel
like crazy I'm obsessed with all of you
I follow you on the gram I follow you on
all the social media platforms except
the Facebook I mean who really I am but
every time I look at her I'm like why
haven't I just deleted this yet yeah I
mean I my I haven't deleted my profile
but I don't know that I've actually
dusted it off in years I kind of feel
though since Facebook owns Instagram
that if we do that slapping them in the
face they're gonna know yeah what's your
favorite social media platform what do
you go to and you open your phone answer
yeah remember you're a visual person
I think aesthetics kind of lend
themselves obviously to Instagram that's
where we all just fall into a deep
Instagram hole in their trailer when
we're in between scenes trying to ignore
each other like each other
mm well you could say we'd have to kind
of zone out and just sometimes forget
each other's there yeah no I travel with
my friends and work with my friends a
lot and I know did you guys did any of
you know each other before this okay
so yeah that's a quick adaptation to
like no we've gone from zero hours spent
together to 24 hours spent together what
are our like unspoken rules socially
with each other like do you guys kind of
understand each other's triggers now if
I go I'm gonna give him space right now
one also you know if you think about how
much time you spend with your best
friend yeah maybe a few hours a week
mm-hmm you know at the most maybe eight
hours a week you are really close we
spend eight to 10 hours a day a day for
two years that so we literally spent
more time with each other
and probably lifelong best friends have
their entire lives so nuts oh yeah we
know how to push each other it's kind of
nice I feel like the real level of
friendship comes when you know how to
exist in silence with each other where
you don't have to fill space and you can
understand that like none of us need to
interact right now we can coexist but we
don't need to try and like come up with
games to play to fill the time sometimes
I think the silence makes Jonathan
nervous so have you guys come up with
any sort of like your own personal games
or like time passers huh or is it just
kind of the norm the norm yeah yeah top
of my head I don't think there's any
little games we play except just you
know life just like just being alive and
living and thriving and he's foolish you
have a very amazing singing voice what's
your go-to karaoke song hmm
you know I think it's because ultimately
my dream was to always be a singer
really and so karaoke is triggering to
old American Idol did they change the
age uh
oh I didn't even know that there was an
age limit is it like becoming the
president oh that seems a little I would
love to see a six-year-old get up there
and just [ __ ] wait that's what
America's Got Talent is for anyone can
get up there thank you for schooling me
on this I also don't although I don't
watch American Idol either really okay
what you do
idle came out I mean God in the late 90s
I don't think I ever see more than like
maybe two minutes of an episode really
because I'm like I mean America's Got
Talent
you can do it I think there's still time
I think it can happen the okay I'm super
curious I'm sure you talked about this a
million times
what was the audition process like for
you on query Oh I mean you've seen
American Idol or America's Got Talent
yeah I've seen you've seen the Hunger
Games and imagine that all gay and then
that was the audition but wait a day I
mean cuz let's go through you and I have
something in common
we both worked at Applebee's I worked at
two different attributes in New Jersey
so as I was just talking about not being
able to watch American Idol literally
the memory I went back to was sitting in
the parking lot at Applebee's in Denver
talking to one of the girls that I
worked with and she was talking about
American Idol and I was like I just
can't watch it and that's the memory I
had told you about that I'm gonna bring
up all of these very classic Americana
suburban dream things right oh man no
one really ate well in that neighborhood
tequila-lime chicken was so good we were
there when they had the Weight Watchers
menu debuted the WW menu where with
everything was calorie and controlled
and all of that and so that's what all
of the servers at the restaurant that I
worked at would eat on our breaks
because we knew that it's all
pre-portioned and prepackaged that the
kitchen didn't touch it yeah they only
they literally put it in the microwave
and they heated it up and so we knew
that there was no foul play involved
with it so that's absolutely like a
bunch of eighteen year olds eating like
just plain chicken and like sauteed
peppers remember um one day it was our
holiday party uh-huh so the restaurant
we were closing early at 7:00 and I like
6:58 this family came in and the hostess
was like oh you know I'm so sorry we're
actually closing at 7:00 tonight our
holiday party and they looked at their
watch and they're like oh I guess we
just made it didn't we
I'm like you have no idea what you guys
ate that night I know I still think that
there should be because I worked in
every chain restaurant I've done like
good Chili's the Applebee's the Olive
Garden Tuesdays
oh wow see I didn't even get that far my
highest achievement was dave & buster's
I only lasted a month so not the best
situation but I still to this day
believe that people in high school
should have a course in like serving
restaurant like business just
interacting with humans that way because
it really is a study in how humans
interact with the world my husband for
some reason his dream is to open up a
restaurant like but no I'm just like
it's because you've never worked in a
restaurant he's a doctor his first job
was blockbuster you know he never worked
in a restaurant and I'm like you don't
understand like especially an individual
one like as an owner you got to be there
all the time I'm gonna do a restaurant
it'll run smoothly no you live there
okay so talk us through them so you
worked in Applebee's in Denver I worked
at Applebee's first in Springfield
Missouri
yeah Branson Missouri hell yeah and I
the Branson Missouri I still live in
Springfield it was like an hour away
hour and a half he was I would I would
drive on Friday morning and I would work
a bell
open to closed Friday I'm gonna sleep in
the parking lot in my car and then I'd
work and hoping to close Saturday sleep
in the parking lot my car and then an
open a closed Sunday and then drive home
oh my cuz if you work lunch shifts
during the week sometimes you literally
make like your dollars yeah no I and
then also sometimes when you work lunch
shifts on the weekends you make as much
people did on Tuesday night yep yeah so
you got a game the system so that's nuts
okay and so then from Missouri you moved
to Denver and then in Denver is where
you started to get into design furniture
yes so I was still in Denver I I moved
there as the assistant manager of the
body shop at the airport and I was
making 20
four thousand dollars a year well I was
like oh I can't believe I'm making so
much money I'd school degree no
seriously I mean I was in Missouri
working at like a gas station in the gap
and I was like making nothing so I got
insane and then like there a month I'm
like oh my god I'm so bored with Denver
so expensive that's true so I ended up
going back to Apple pieces to work part
time as well really I had to have two
jobs and then I worked at was a human
resource manager at the gap you know I
just did nothing but in the jar at the
gap yeah I did nothing but interview you
know sixteen-year-old girls all day long
I wanted to work at the gap and then
next week they'd quit because they had
to work the weekends and they had some
where they were right he said all I did
was just interview people over and over
and over because we're constantly
filling Wow and then I work at the
bomb-bay company I worked at Express I
was a youngest store manager and Express
history I couldn't even operate the
trash compactor because I wasn't in
every place you can imagine it a
suburban mall um actually I can tell a
little part of it so I met the owner
recently of American Eagle an American
signature furniture at DSW and I was
just talking to him and he's telling me
stories and he mentioned American Eagle
and then I was like wait a minute
I used to work for you payroll yes oh
god um so then where did where does
furniture and design fit into this like
I was always into design but in Missouri
like that wasn't really something you
did sure there weren't really designers
the only the only decorators I ever saw
were designing women' you know with
Delta Burke everything you have that you
know and I remember when I went into
Target I was probably eight or nine and
they're very you know they're big on
their designer collaborations yeah very
first of the Cynar collaboration was
with Michael Graves was an architect and
he had these amazing toasters and tea
kettles and spatulas and that was the
first time I looked at products and
items as something that was designed but
where I was a sight
the exact moment I remember standing
there looking up at all these spatulas
going these are so cool it's not just
you know a spoon it's not just something
that you spoon stuff with a spoon is
something that can bring you joy yeah it
can look cool too you know and it's that
was my first time I thought about
there's people out there that are making
things pretty and thinking about the way
things make you feel hmm
but again that wasn't really something
into Missouri I thought was ever an
option for me
sure so then in Denver I worked for the
Bombay company which was a retail
furniture store okay and then I've got
me into liking that is that more and
then after the Bombay company I went
through L'Occitane I mean I've worked
for pretty much every we don't go but he
out there and then I went to work for a
committee called Great Indoors
okay which was owned by Sears it was
this massive it was kind of like a Home
Depot meets a furniture store I mean it
was like apply like a best buy anything
you could want for your home it was in
this massive store sadly they didn't
make it they had familiar yeah it wasn't
a concept that worked but um after that
I really got into design even more and
then I came to New York to meet up with
a friend and I ended up meeting a boy
and fell in love and decided I was gonna
move to New York and that relationship
not even lasts until I got to New York
but I fell in love with the city too
yeah and so I decided that I was gonna
move to New York and I didn't have a job
I just like I'll just get a job at
Applebee's restaurant you know I had
tons of restaurant experience in Denver
I also worked at a high-end Italian
restaurant as well that was owned by the
mob you'd a spectrum of opportunity I
can always just do that yeah the so I
got to New York with like a hundred
bucks in a suitcase and quickly learned
that restaurants will not hire you in
New York unless you have a New York City
experience yes this is very true so it
took me about three months to find a job
and that was Restoration Hardware oh
really
that was the first job you got New York
yeah I was they hired me as a design
manager at Restoration Hardware Wow so I
worked there I want to say like three
months before I got fired I've been
fired from every job I've ever had by
the way
yeah that's the chrissy teigen and i
relate on that her i would both been
fired from every single job we've ever
had the funny thing is so i got fired
while tom Felicia was upstairs holding
queer oh wait I saw this when you guys
said the special where you guys are all
like having a brunch together and
talking about everything yeah I heard
you tell him that he was upstairs
filming not knowing that the little boy
that would one day fill his shoes was
getting fired but you also can have a
clean slate of saying you're not a
quitter because you've literally never
quit a job you know that's the thing
like I almost think I would get fired on
purpose because I'm not a quitter like I
will not quit something yeah unless I
have another job at even then I still
didn't so I like I think sometimes we're
just sabotage myself dislike
I remember in New York after Restoration
Hardware I went to work for Bed Bath
Beyond well back then the one on 18th
Street in New York was the only bit
beyond in New York more business than
most bad betting on districts do in a
month Wow there was a room upstairs
where people just set and counted cash
there was those tubes where the
registers just shot cash into the room
and it was like but quacky duck what was
his name
I ran the whole front end so the cash
registers check out and the customer
service and Bed Bath Beyond has a very
open return policy yes they do so it was
just nothing but you know soiled sheets
and plungers hair bags we called them
Renta beds because they'd go out on
Friday and they'd come back on Monday
Wow
it was just it was it was an intense job
so West Elm was opening up their second
store they have just been acquired by
William Sonoma they're open if their
first big store on 1786 yeah yeah and so
I'm like I want to work for this cute
new I faxed my resume to them from work
and Bed Bath Beyond is very um budget
focus sure and so you don't get
confirmation is that your faxes went
that would be a waste of paper but what
happened was you get a confirmation if
it doesn't go through okay so I walked
away thinking it went through but it
didn't so it copied the first page of my
resume and spit it back out saying it
didn't go through
oh no and another manager that I had
just been promoted over founded Oh God
so Jennifer hi Jennifer she took it to
the general manager and I actually had a
meeting that day with him to talk about
how I want to change up scheduling and
like new systems and we had a great
meeting and he's like this is awesome
and I've never had somebody come in here
this quickly and like change things for
the better
and he's like what the [ __ ] is this I
like slides of the cross a desk and I
just looked at him and I go the [ __ ] do
you expect you think somebody that's
coming in here and have a great idea
that is gonna stare like she's horrible
you know they would give I'm totally
ruined any chance I ever have of any
collaborations with resources had a deal
that if I were to get you to come work
about bathroom as a manager and you
stayed for three months mm-hmm I'd get a
three thousand dollar bonus oh they
never had to pay that it was a lot it
was a very you know it might be better
other stores that were if like I said
James is that stores but it was funny I
filmed a segment for Rachael Ray a few
months ago and they were like we want
you to film in a bed bath neon on six
Avenue and I'm like triggered okay so
I'm walking through with all like that's
corporate PR people marketing team I'm
walking through I'm like oh you're right
up there's where I got fired right over
there's where I used to cry and that's
there is where I got fired and there's
what she's came back a little dirtier
than I'd hoped
yeah my only connection to that Bed Bath
& Beyond I I did improv in New York at a
theater that was nearby and that's where
I would go and take nervous shits before
going to the theater to perform that was
you that was me cuz the bathrooms right
behind customer service and I would walk
in with full confidence
you came and you passed the return desk
you went to the left contact but no one
I went straight in and straight out it
was the Beyond part of Bath and Beyond
truly magical that stores provide ok
this is amazing take one quick break
when we get back with more of Bobbie
Burke and we'll find out where the [ __ ]
else he's been fired from oh not your
deepest brought to you by Bud Light are
you craving flavor and refreshment this
summer then pick up one of three flavors
of Bud Light shilada original extra lime
and the newest member of the chillout a
family mango but like shilada is perfect
for drinking at brunch
on the beach we're just hanging out with
friends in the Sun the original gelato
brings you the crisp refreshing taste of
Bud Light with the rich signature taste
of Clamato tomato cocktail this
distinctive blend delivers a flavor that
truly it refreshes and the Tata extra
lime delivers a citrusy spin and the
talero mango brings a tropical touch to
the summertime favorite it's best to
enjoy your chilapa
gently rotate the chilled can once
before pouring then pour over ice and
garnish with a slice of lime some celery
or mango salt the rim with your glass at
a dash of hot sauce for even more kick
and even more impressive last etics of
drink people will maybe think that you
made them an original cocktail but you
didn't
you got a Bud Light chill out on your
hands pick up a Bud Light chill out of
today and learn more at Bud Light calm
Bud Light shilada a flavor that
refreshes support for today's show comes
from bareMinerals creators of clean
beauty purity in formulation and
uncompromising performance have always
been the guiding principles of bare
minerals because they believe that
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking this
has been the bareMinerals philosophy
since it began the clean beauty
revolution in 1995 with their
best-selling original foundation it's
got creamy lightweight buildable
coverage it's naturally luminous the
clean formula is made with only 5 good
for you
skin angry
all minerals including non-chemical SPF
protection its makeup so pure you can
sleep in it and it actually improves
your skin over time what more could you
want
it's everything your skin needs and
nothing it doesn't because for bare
minerals to be clean without compromise
means good for skin formulas with proven
performance and like every bare minerals
product it's 100% cruelty free and
better yet both the original and that
loose powder foundations are available
in 30 shades so upgrade to clean beauty
products use their foundation finder at
bare minerals calm you can find your
perfect match and first time customers
will get 15% off when you use the promo
code not too deep that's bare minerals
calm promo code not too deep for 15% off
your first purchase bare minerals the
power of good you're like in your 20s
and you're like New York as hard as [ __ ]
but it's fine you're in your 20s you're
poor it's fine that you care but still
kind of resilient you know it like I
didn't even have money for cabs or the
subway so that first three months I look
for a job I was walking around in June
July August yeah you know and then were
you there I was there 2008 to 2002 late
yeah I was Oh 2007 to 2012 ish I got
there in 2003 and like fill in the like
the last I like the grunge cool bars
that Giuliani hat and cleaned up yet
we're still there and so I'd walk from I
lifted 8th Avenue and 15th Street ok
know that like cinder block grey
building and you'd know it if you saw it
yes and so I'd walk all the way across
the island to Lower East Side on the
city of bollène and all the great bars
it was there I was in Brooklyn the whole
time when I lived there but and then I
would go into the city and perform but
and do auditions and basically just run
around like a crazy person but twenties
it's great you're like life is hard
life's supposed to be hard I'm in my 20s
I'm poor this is great I'll make you
something I'm
living the musical Rent right now and
then you hit your 30s and like it for me
I was doing okay I had a store my
husband was I'd finished residency it
was a doctor and we're like life is
still hard like it's a fight to get on
the elevator it's a fight to walk down
the street it's a night to get on the
subway it's like to walk down the
sidewalk and I'm like life should not be
this angry I remember yeah things like
two or three years before we were
finally like you just the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah friends of mine came to visit from
San Diego and another friend of ours we
got a little house in the Hamptons for
the weekend and you know I'm like twittg
and I'm in New Yorker and it's smoking
my cigarettes and our friend Billy and
Michael they were there and people are
like oh how a San Diego house yeah when
you're like oh it's just it's chill you
know it's just real chill and I remember
thinking myself like imagining
strangling them going if they say chill
one more time I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
them yeah but then now people from New
York are like how's LA I'm like it's a
joke people that had lived here in
California for a long time same exact
thing that they were so I was like I'm
offended by how relaxed you are like
like I don't understand why you're not
on edge the way I'm on it mad at me for
taking up too much space right now one
of the first times they came out here to
LA I was at Starbucks I was with a
friend of mine who had lived in New York
but had since moved to LA okay and we're
we walk into Starbucks and there's like
nobody at the register and I walk up I'm
standing there and I look over and
there's this woman like bent down behind
the coffee machine like cleaning
something and I was like and she leans
up and she's like I am so sorry and I
instantly was gonna be like [ __ ] you my
friend again who had lived in New York
and LA now put her hand on my shoulder
and says she's like oh oh thank you oh
nice and then a week later I was at a
Starbucks and it's my idea can't I live
my life in her standing in Starbucks
with another friend who had lived in New
York now in LA
mm-hm and I see this guy like kind of
nervously over there like you know
squeezing his hand like he's clearly in
a rush uh-huh and I had just seen one of
the baristas drop a coffee so I'm like
oh that was probably his yeah and so
finally he's like oh I'm sorry is there
you know an iced americano on its way up
you know I'm in a huge hurry and she's
like I'm so sorry I was making it and it
slipped out of my hand I'm so sorry I'm
making you another one now he's like you
know what I don't have time if you could
just pour me an iced coffee and she's
like I'm so sorry he's like no don't
apologize it's my fault I should have
given myself more time to get to my
Starbucks you know I worked at a store
portico and then I had my store on
Crosby between spring and Broome and
that Starbucks on the corner of Spring
and Broome was like my Starbucks for
like a decade and I remember like so
many mornings like cursing people out in
there because they were being so mean to
the bar Easter's and I'd be like [ __ ]
cup of coffee [ __ ] like why are you
ruining this poor girl's day over a cup
of coffee relax oh yeah I have a hard
time accepting the sincerity I
immediately interpret it as sarcasm and
so I'm on the defense right away and I
have to chill the [ __ ] out because I'm
like you don't you're not you do not
from New Jersey anymore and you're not
living in New York anymore so calm the
[ __ ] down I've gotten better now like I
can yeah a sense of Zen
yeah but you also okay let's talk about
travel you've been traveling like crazy
has there been and like for the last two
years you guys have just been like all
over the place yes and no our show has
only been out for one year in two months
but how long we started filming in April
no May of 2017 okay so we were in
Atlanta for almost six months right then
from UM from September
until excuse me from September until
February hmm we had nothing like no one
knew who we were what was that waiting
period like that launched like we didn't
sing and now we have to let someone we
let people edit it and then hope it goes
well like okay now we have the time of
just sitting there and waiting for
people to like hate our show sure none
of us thought people were gonna like it
like we all there was gonna be a flop or
like oh this was really yeah that's so
no cuz the press that came out before
the show actually launched none of it
was positive
Oh everyone's like what do we need to
show for now like this is not the time
like this is just offensive that they
think that this show would work nowadays
like wow five gay guys would come in and
like redo this straight guy like yeah so
we're like oh god yeah I mean it wasn't
but so yeah it came out February 7th
2018 and then I mean it did well but it
wasn't until season 2 yeah that I think
it really exploded I think that's when I
started when season 2 came out is when I
heard a lot of people talking about it
and then I fully binge watched in like
two days all of it I know why so season
one the producers had a very specific
idea in their mind of what they wanted
me to look like oh yeah I think one of
the words they use was waspey then what
it need to be this preppy little blonde
like pastel color wearing guy from
Connecticut Oh literally look cost is
what they wanted me in Wow and by the
end of season one I'm like I you can't
fire me now I am not wearing this
anymore right so season two was more
successful because you guys are more
yourself yeah no I'm kidding but I know
that I'm not kidding about the colors
yeah someone that you know has an eye
for aesthetic sure like I don't want
this is not who I am it's not a show
that you're encouraging people to be
authentically themselves like here's why
I well a the show did not start out like
that
but I think and then it was David
Collins the creator of the show that how
does I need his money and I think it was
because he had been there from the
beginning from the original and
there was Carson he was the blonde yet
he wore the bright color as he was a
preppy and I think in his mind he was
like alright Bobby's the blonde
he needs to dress like kind of like
Carson did yes and you know because he
hadn't seen the new iteration yet he
just had in his mind what the original
show and how it was successful why it
was successful and how successful the
original Fab Five were so he's like
alright we're gonna do it the same we're
gonna do it formula where this formula
works why would we change our you're the
blonde where a lot of bright colors you
know and so there was nothing that he
was trying to like make me not be myself
and it's just he had it in his mind
here's a successful formulation why
would we deviate from that yeah and so
in the beginning it was we really were
I'm sorry we were talking about
traveling then we got on them no I'm so
yeah we it was kind of a fight between
us and the original creators of the show
not a fight just kind of a heads yeah
because again they had a winning formula
they knew it worked they knew it was
super successful so they're like let's
do it like that right and we were like
no 2018 we don't think five gay guys
going into a straight guy's house and
telling him everything that's wrong with
you and ripping him apart and me ripping
their house apart and breaking things
yeah I don't think that's gonna work now
I mean people are gonna be like yeah
exactly we didn't need this again so
like how about we go in and we find
everything that's great about them
because clearly these people don't see
anything great about themselves that's
why they're on this show and build them
up yeah you know in this show being
about building people up and self-love
and so in the beginning it again not a
fight but a you know a fight of creative
minds of our discovery days are
discovering we that's the day one
Tuesday's where we going and we meet
them and we start tearing apart the
house and looking right and it was
always like do more tear apart more and
we're like no I'm not gonna go in I'm
like and their wives are there too and
be like this house is yeah I'm like he
doesn't want to decorate it break this
poor woman's heart that's not what we're
gonna do so it wasn't until probably
like season our episode four we're
finally like dug our heels in and we're
like no let us do this yeah and then it
came out and they were like yes this
works now
that makes sense because also you're
watching and you're creating a show that
you would want to watch if you weren't
part of it you know that's kind of like
my litmus test for creating anything is
like if I heard this or saw this or
whatever would I want to watch it myself
and and the original show definitely was
groundbreaking and it's time in a time
period you know real gay people on TV
even Jack from Will and Grace II hadn't
even technically come out as real-life
yet yeah so the world was okay with five
gay guys on television as long as they
were these like Carly dress yeah
over-the-top gay got not that they were
over-the-top gay guys but you know they
post like a throwback photo of like
their their fashion designers and their
haircuts and their cookers and their
designers and like the world was okay as
long as we stood in our lane of being
those creative gays right but it
wouldn't have been okay if you know they
had talked about their husbands and
their boyfriends and wanting kids and
like actually being real people yeah
we're us we wanted to make sure that we
were seen as real people and not those
caricatures of what people think gays
are right we wanted everyone in Middle
America who may have not ever met a gay
person or in Ethiopia or Saudi Arabia
where we are air as well to see us as
just regular guys you're fully normed
human beings at the end of the day
that's it I respected so much too
episode where you didn't want to go into
the church and that was for me a real
like kind of turning point of like oh
this is a real show like these are
people that are having real reactions a
producer didn't set up this moment for
you to have like trouble for that but I
mean to be fair it's the most honest
situation and like very very cool
regardless of what happened behind the
scenes of everything I think it was
really awesome to see that that was
allowed you know that that was like a
real moment on TV that you were you're
not acting uncomfortable you are
genuinely uncomfortable and you're
standing up for yourself without making
the other person feel bad or making
anyone else feel bad and I was just like
this is very cool to see even if I'm
sure it was probably awkward and weird
in the the creator of the show David was
upset with me um
and this is again no knocking David cuz
David David's very religious he goes to
church so I um he looked at it as me
being disrespectful and he was like I
can't believe he did that not going in
there it was so disrespectful and I'm
like we had to come to Jesus no pun
intended the conversation where I was
like it wasn't me being disrespectful it
was just me protecting my own mental
health you know that's a trigger for me
yeah and in the end he was like I get it
you're right you know I'm sorry it just
for me being religious loving the church
I saw that as a slap in the face and
he's like I see now that it wasn't him
you know the cool thing is like it's a
conversation starter to say the least
about that scene that I was like this is
really cool because things like exactly
that it causes people to start asking
questions about where is the offense
there's no real offense it's everyone
has their own story in their own history
and their own like relationship with
religion in some way and I think it's
really cool to be able in a very kind of
genuine like it was subtle to it didn't
seem like it was this big like I was
just like oh man yeah and that's what I
was like cool this is very cool I like
the direction that this is all going
right now and I'm sure you've gotten
probably a lot of feedback about that
specific moment from a lot of people
that have been raised in a very
religious I mean I I can't honestly even
keep up with the messages and yet still
get about that episode but one that
really stood out to me and I think it
was a combination of the body the babi
camp episode with all the kids and the
momma Tammy episode because bobby was in
season one mama was in season two a
pastor messaged me and he's like my
entire life in church I was taught that
gays were wrong gays were bad gays were
an abomination that it was a choice to
live this Sodom and Gomorrha lifestyle
and that's what I've taught in my church
as well I've taught that God hates gays
and blah blah blah but seeing the
episode where you talk about every day
of your life crying and begging and
praying God to make you not gay he's
like literally changed my life and I
will never teach that hate in my church
again I will never teach my congregation
or anyone that being gay is is wrong and
then it's a choice an abomination he's
like it really made me see that you are
born that way and it's not a choice and
if you're are born that way how can I
believe that God you know is the
all-powerful and nothing happens for a
reason everything
God's plan at but then also at the same
time say oh well you couldn't you know
if you were born that way it's wrong
well I was born that way because you
know quote-unquote God made me that way
he's like I can't I can't make that work
together so I just have to accept it wow
that's so intense and beautiful and
wonderful and in the amount of other
messages I've gotten from people in
congregations or pastors who have said
they have told their congregation that
watching queer is homework well really
you need to go home and specifically
watch the the Bobby camp episode and
then I'm on the Tami episode so even
though I'm still not part of the church
I don't have any desire to be just the
fact that our show is maybe well it's
definitely helping young LGBTQ youth not
go through the self-hate yeah that a lot
of us had to go through going up yeah no
it's right there is life the impact is
immeasurable I can imagine that it's one
of those things that's now just fully
taken off that it's like you you guys
are all seemingly genuine wonderful
souls that I'm sure you want to keep up
with all the messages that you get but I
can imagine that it's so overwhelming
that even to start like responding to
people and replying and like looking
through your dm's and things like that
must be just like a first day the show
came out I remember that I woke up of
course we're on the west coast I woke up
after people already started watching it
and I started looking at my DMS and
started responding I went out like late
on the sofa and the next time I looked
at the clock it was 7 p.m. and I had
been up at like 6:00 I'm like oh god I
just fell down a deep hole at the end
and then for the first few months I did
I really kept up on him and it actually
started causing problems between my
husband and I because if I was home I
was on the sofa I wasn't watching TV but
now I wasn't doing anything I was
responding so I finally I actually I
have one of my team does my not all my
social media but she makes sure that
we're surrounding the people keeping it
up because I had to detach myself from
it and it as well yeah because both of
our husbands were like put your phones
down but we felt such an obligation to
to respond to these people that we had
had an effect on because we didn't want
them to think that it was bullsh
that we're a cake or like we really want
to genuinely connect with them but we
just couldn't
oh it's impossible it's an impossible
task I also think it's really cool that
you and Tim both openly talk about your
relationships on the show was that a
conscious choice message us yesterday
and they're like funny thing is my mom
and I all the way through season one and
two went Anna Bobby would talk about how
they were married we thought they were
married to each other not the first time
I've heard that
dan and I will say I'm like you know tan
and I are married
tan and I are both married I will be
like Bobby and I are both married and so
many people think that were married to
each other I think it totally happened
like he's totally my type cute little
brown boy he loves the pasty white boys
like his husband and I could be brothers
he could my husband and him could be
cousins yeah that could be easily
misinterpreted but yes it was a
conscious effort because again like I
said the original guys didn't have the
freedom to be able to talk about the
fact that they were real people they
were husbands they were parents or
whatever you know and so we really
wanted to make sure that we did in car
amo as well really wanted to make sure
that he talked about yeah yeah you know
so people would think oh amazing sweet
wonderful gay people can be parents
they're not you know like awful
propaganda that's out there about you
know gay parents raise horrible kids and
blah blah blah you know we really wanted
to see that yeah one of those guys that
you think this is one of the sweetest
guys in the world he's a dad amazing
wonderful white boys like it's almost
uncomfortable how polite Christian Jason
our I'm just like you don't need to call
me mr. Bobby just they're just they're
so sweet and well-behaved I mean
grandmas like they're such pain in the
ass but you know like as all kids are to
their dad but he's done such a good job
with those boys they're so polite
they're so respectful fantastic so smart
and intelligent he did a really good job
with them was your husband on board
about you being so open about the
relationship publicly yeah I mean we
think it okay to compare yeah we've been
together for 15 years yes
like we're solid you know we've we've
always been very open I'm like I don't I
don't think it was ever a conversation
because it was it's not really it
shouldn't be a conversation yeah yeah
I'm married I have a husband like that's
just it's not a secret yeah I know I
think it's so great you guys on your
Instagram are cute as heck your photos
together are literal couple goals
constantly you guys just went to PF
Changs and had a date this is when I saw
that you worked at Applebee's and that
you and your husband just went on a date
to PF Changs I was like we're just like
so sisters this is my favorite so I was
landing from North Carolina I was out
dealing with the launch of my new
furniture line and he was getting on a
plane to go to New York he still goes
back he has an office in Darien
Connecticut he's a doctor he goes back
once a month for his patients there and
we hadn't seen each other in two weeks
and so we got like two and a half hours
together you know he came to the airport
a little early and you know the only
like longtime dining location in the
airport was PF Changs so we're like well
let's go to PF Changs friend like we
don't even have to be arriving or
departing on a plane I just want to go
to LAX and go to PF Changs as you please
okay we're gonna take one last quick
break and when we get back I have a
million Twitter questions for you if you
do not mind we'll be right back with
Bobbie Burke on Notre Dame for years
we've been told that clean meant one
thing sanitized it's supposed to be
healthy but sanitizers and disinfectants
wipe out everything all the good healthy
stuff along with any bad like your gut
your home is a microbiome to surprise
surprise a research is starting to show
that this kilomole approach may be going
too far with negative effects on our
health especially for kids but right now
aunt Fanny's what a great name brings
probiotics to your home and your hands
with their new microcosmic line these
household cleaners and hand soaps add
good with probiotic power each has an
extract of beneficial bacteria plus
super effective plant-based ingredients
to be tough on dirt and gentle
on you these formulas are non-toxic
cruelty-free and have 100% essential oil
sense so no fake fragrances they're
hypoallergenic and dermatologist tested
too
what a great way to keep your home clean
and also keep all the good the good
stuff that you need but that you kids so
your pets don't need so why just stop at
natural cleaning when you can do one
better with probiotics shop now at aunt
Fanny's calm / good and get 20% off your
entire order with the coupon code graced
grac e at checkout again that's aunt
Fanny's calm / good coupon code grace
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by smile direct Club they
straighten your teeth for 60% less than
braces with clear aligners sent directly
to you you simply go online and you book
a free 3d image at one of their smile
shops how cute or you can order an
at-home impression kit and you'll be
emailed a preview of your new smile and
once you get your aligners 1 of smile
direct clubs duly licensed doctors will
check in on your progress every 90 days
most new smiles take six months on
average so visit smile direct club.com
for free real before-and-after photos
from some of five hundred and fifty
thousand plus satisfied grin nurse also
cute Ellen why I said they're free
photos and getting my words mixed up but
you'll get to see all the real
before-and-after photos again get a free
3d image of your smile at one of smile
direct clubs smile shops or a $25 rebate
on an at-home impression kit then just
for you beautiful listeners you will
receive $100 off your clear aligners
when you go to smile direct club.com /
podcast and use the offer code grace 100
that's $100 off at smile direct club.com
/ podcast offer code grace one zero zero
smile direct club.com / podcast offer
code grace 100 there's an instagram
griffin the Frenchie
yeah i love him
sportive season right no no that's
brouilly that's my husband and I
actually had a Frenchy she was searching
she passed away while we were filming
season 13 yeah like she lived before
that was an old woman yes that's right
her name was Lola I followed too many
French bulldogs and Instagram it's a
real problem really is our little our
little boy on the show he lives here in
LA oh really
yep wait so he's not one of yours action
oh no he was one of our producers who
lives here in LA it was her dog and like
he would just walk on two sad laughs
either and we're like brutally out and
he's like just sit down and so that was
like the very first episode we're like
you know what let's just roll with this
because we all loved well all of us
patan loved dogs
so cute season one I had to carry him in
the beginning of the episode because a
dog and we were we were filming with a
dog the other day and it was the
sweetest most-loving and she wasn't even
a big dog she was like part Corgi part
something no oh my god but she sneezed
literally I mean you would have thought
that Godzilla had just basically jumped
up in the sofa and we were all like she
was like coming after me okay we're
gonna get into these Twitter questions
before we do I'm gonna ask you the two
questions asked every single guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at cold spaghetti
yes sir well not having ever had cold
spaghetti thrown at me I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing
it's up for your own interpretation mmm
buttered cold spaghetti
sure it could be it's good I wanna throw
cold spaghetti yet so you know I don't
think it would be very nice so let's
think of somebody I don't like okay hmm
I mean I gotta say Trump yeah did it his
hair yeah he could never get it out like
you have to like cut it out of the three
strands he has he might put some like
Kraft powder cheese on it and just make
it like his hair he'd make it fashion
not fashion he'd make it
bad hair that's a great answer okay the
other question is to tell us your worst
pants shooting story or close call but
you can only use you can only use three
words or three small phrases so mine for
instance is college jogging front lawn
kindergarten all over the town you can
use small phrases it's okay
kindergarten outside of my okay let's
get into the Twitter questions we have a
million for you popping up on Twitter
these yesterday's they're always the
most informative thing for me for every
guest to see like how people respond to
whoever is gonna be on and people really
have quite a relationship with you okay
someone to know what is the definitive
answer to proper toilet paper placement
over over okay well why why well I mean
the idea of under yeah you're just like
you why would you want to reach under to
grab it that doesn't make any sense like
I mean the only reach around I want to
do does not involve toilet paper
okay so once no only the only an
appropriate comment firing I ever got
was from MCI hi this is Bobbi with MCI
do you like your long-distance carrier
oh that is really good I mean you should
be in the commercial someone to know
what's a plant that I can't kill a
plastic one oh okay are you a pro or no
artificial plants um I am neither pro
nor know I think that there's a time in
a place I think that there are a lot of
great ones out there that if you have a
room that doesn't have the right
sunlight that you just can't grow
something I think green makes you happy
whether it's bakery good and
aesthetically it looks nice it adds
texture it adds a natural element so if
you get a good one and they don't have
the right sunlight or you travel a lot
yeah that's a big one yeah like
technology artificial plants are
starting to look more and more realistic
I'm gonna get some of those fiddle figs
that everyone is so up in arms that I
give to everyone not Bobby give a fiddle
fig to everyone they're just gonna kill
it what is he thinking with they're not
all real calm the [ __ ] down
bring me some different plants then
someone's know what this Kurama smell
like because I imagine it's heavenly a
few weeks ago everybody left like the
blanket he was covered up with because
he's always cold smelled like a but I
just laid there my Tobin smell that I
don't know what clone he wears but it's
it's nice yeah oh it smells nice you
guys I am I mean you smell amazing and
you guys I imagine all smell great like
that's not like you're not driving an
SUV full of like body odor around unless
maybe you are sometimes a little bit of
an expiration date
[Laughter]
a lot of people are asking this same
type of question what's the grossest
thing in someone's home that wasn't
shown on the show um
dirty diapers on the floor and like like
disposed of dirty diapers Wow and an
animal feces
and rotten food okay here's a question
when you guys what do you call it when
you go in for the first day discovery
discovery day how are you guys really
going in blind like they really haven't
told you other than what you have in
like your dossier about the person or do
you kind of know pletely going and blind
about what we know about the person okay
I'm not going in blind yeah I have to
pre-order flooring and window jam it's
like there's no way I can stores don't
stock that amount of stuff you can't do
that 24 hours um but all the information
about them mm-hmm we're going in blind
we've never met them we've seen a
picture yeah wow that must be so nuts
have you ever had like a bad first
impression day or you're like all of
them are and they're that the particular
episode I'm talking about with the feces
but anytime the cameras weren't rolling
we put on masks really yeah it was a
situation the air quality smell lethal
yes well you guys put it off very well
so kudos you asking how does he feel
being the true MVP of queer I because
you really and there's so many jokes
that float around of like Anthony says
put an avocado on it and you give them a
whole [ __ ] new house we all have our
roles
none of it would work without each and
every one of our roles it's just a given
that interior design is more labor
intensive I mean season 1 & 2 I was
definitely in there way more because my
team was way smaller right but no I have
an amazing team my my art director Tommy
he was a art director for Extreme Home
Makeover oh cool so like he knows how to
build a house oh yeah yeah so without
him that I wouldn't get any of this done
because he really knows how to make sure
that everything we need gets there when
it's supposed to yeah oh that's great
that's so helpful and then you guys get
into a rhythm of working together and
you're sure it's gotten slightly easy
its season 1 & 2 as you know they were
shot together it was all intertwined so
it was that's learning each other it was
him learning me it was me learning him
and by the time we got to season 3 he
knows exactly like he can walk into a
store be like Bobby would want that one
we basically build out our own
little store so I usually go out there
one to two weeks before the other boys
okay and we get a warehouse and we fill
it full of shelves and we just start
ordering tons of stuff gotcha
um art vases plants bedding inserts like
a little side tables lamps and we just
fill this warehouse full of stuff and so
that way that week I can after meeting
the hero and figuring out who they are
and what they like I can go into my
store and that's why you don't see a lot
of shopping scenes a I don't like really
promoting like I don't want to just be
sure the trade out [ __ ] like yeah I
don't like there are the stores that I
go to and this the show are actually
really stores that yeah like I love West
I'm I work with that so I'm all the time
with the Pottery Barn Container Store
mm-hmm so so it's it's I go in there I
pick everything out and then we have a
big box truck that has shelves down the
side okay I fill that up and then we
park that in front of the house while
we're doing it and we go out and we shop
in our little truck and we're like this
will work and this will work great I'm
here we rarely do we have to run to a
store and be like we don't have enough
stuff because we've we've pre thought
out and got tons of different genres of
different things and looks yeah that
makes sense it's also because I didn't
like the hero of your show is already so
overwhelmed by everything that the last
thing they want to do is pick out like
furniture well then they can I mean most
of them I would say nine out of ten say
their favorite home stores Walmart right
and that's not a home even though they
have a new mid-century modern collection
there is super cute but yeah that's just
especially in those areas like some of
the more suburban Walmart stores have
actually really cute home department but
the ones in like the middle of Missouri
Atlanta they don't really yeah so they
they don't know what they like they I
could be like you like this sofa one
episode coming out in season four I
actually do take him to West Elm and
it's somebody who has a never decade
like he's never lived in his own home it
was an older gentleman like lived with
his family as older dinh with his
parents take care of them
and so he had never decorated a place
for himself so he had literally zero
idea of what he liked
to the store and like you like that oh
yeah that's great yeah do you like that
oh yeah that's great and I can purposely
point to like ugly stuff and be like
you're like yeah that's great cuz you've
told me you like everything yeah and you
can't he's like well no it's all great
I'm like yeah you know some of them like
they give me nothing yeah a lot of those
people like what your walls blue or gray
cuz they didn't give me anything I know
they're gonna like we were happy you
know I'm not just gonna throw that's not
what this show is the show is about
using design to affect their lives and
make them happy you know it's not about
me just do and showing all my tricks
right yeah you're not on trading spaces
right now I love the show but the I
think also the thing too with those kind
of small moments is like interior design
is intimidating so it's like showing
people that you can start really simply
and like build around certain like key
elements and like it doesn't have to be
so overwhelming and I've learned quickly
that did the producers just stop even
cuz they usually would get us like a
questionnaire of like you know their
favorite color yeah their favorite
clothing store so tan could maybe get an
idea what their style might be but I
probably say they usually said Walmart
yeah and so I learned them like don't
even bother asking them the design
questions anymore because they like Tom
Jack's in the very first episode I asked
him was like you know what's your design
aesthetic and he's like Oh rusty
muttered and I was like all right
explain to me what rustic modern is to
you and so I quickly learned of like you
know these kinds of and it's not a jab
at them or not then they just decide
just like me growing up in Missouri
design wasn't something you talked about
it's like yeah you put something in
there that was functional yeah the sofas
comfortable all right right no it's a
big climb rather than yeah exactly it's
a recliner it's filled with
but gunk yeah literally that it that
camera did not I'm gonna get dirty it
literally looked like someone had just
lube it was just like there was no
saving next year but I learned to look
at other questions like what's your
dream vacation what's your favorite show
with Remy the guy who had inherited his
grandmother's house that was still a
super stuck in the 70s with shot carpet
he said that his favorite show was Mad
Men and that his dream vacation with
Cuba I'm like alright this guy loves the
50s who loves mid-century you know so I
get kind of a mid-century Flair with
some some coupon Oh in it yeah I think
that's just generally a great place to
start at when you cuz I still struggle
with like going on Pinterest and then
getting overwhelmed by every [ __ ] boho
chic looking office space that I see and
I'm like is this even really my style I
don't know or am I just seeing it over
and over again that I'm conditioning
myself to think this is aesthetically
appealing to me but like what you said
thinking about what shows I like and
thinking about where I want to travel to
are great like stepping stone I work
with clients that really don't have an
idea of what their direction they want
to go and I tell them like pin your
favorite things I'm like and it doesn't
have to be designed paint a sweater it
can be a restaurant it can be food like
if you had all this food that's like
super architectural and structure and
I'm like I'm gonna get an idea that you
like minimalism yeah yeah you know you
like things to be in order you know if
you're pinning food that's all chaotic
and a mess and like you probably like
more of a boho relaxed feel so it's it's
figuring out what people are gonna like
in their lives and design by figuring
out what they like in different parts of
their life that's super smart have you
done a book yet so of course you know
all for the boys have books now and
everyone's like when you're doing a boob
in a book I'm like I just launched a new
75 item collection of furniture that
launched all over Asia and
about to launch in hundreds of stores
here in the US I just launched a massive
new editorial website in a new wallpaper
line a new art collection there's my
[ __ ] book I still run a company you
know I still weren't a huge a design
firm we have a lot of projects and so I
don't have time you know yeah they don't
have day jobs right you know um tan was
lucky enough that he had actually
decided to sell his clothing company
before he even got casted him and Rob
had talked about starting a family I
mean he wanted to really focus on that
so by the time we started filming I
think I like maybe a few weeks in the
sale finalized and he was like I'm done
with that so he's able to just focus on
the show and what's he want and then
krama was doing TV before yeah and
Jonathan was doing hair and he doesn't
really do here much anymore does it for
fun no and then Anthony was doing food
but they all like they don't have a
company in which they they need to be
present they're doing projects it's more
the creative flow I think time for book
and also really do a book and I'm really
gonna talk about everything that has
happened in my family since I moved away
at fifteen years old to the things that
I've had to do to survive the the
entrepreneurial spirit I've always had
whether it be legal businesses or not
you know I'm gonna talk about everything
I think that's great now is not the time
for that yeah I really want to share my
story but my story is nowhere near done
that's I think a very very smart way to
think about it like a book will always
be there yeah it the option will always
be there and your story's only gonna
grow from here until whenever you want
to actually put it into publishing but I
think that's the cool you don't want to
make just like a coffee table here's
like what you can put on it if people
say there's like why don't you just do a
design book I'm like I'll be real Frank
do you don't make anything off a design
books yeah design books takes so much
time and honestly money to put together
photoshoots and styling and and trips
all over the place to put it together
that it costs so much money to do that
you really don't make anything off of it
yeah and they don't really
that well like people who are into
design by them but if you're not a big
person that's into design you're not
gonna spend you know coffee table books
aren't cheap so you know anywhere from
80 to 120 dollars on a book it's not
worth it no that's not I for example
with my furniture line I made my
furniture line very accessible it looks
like it should be a ten thousand dollar
sofa and it's $1,000 so that's you know
the dining chairs look like they should
be a thousand bucks in there 250 I mean
you know and so even with my book I'm
like I don't want to put a book out
that's not gonna be accessible to all of
my hands so it'll be a more maybe
eventually I will do a design book but
right now my also I looked at your
website like you said you have this
amazingly goop esque lifestyle website
going on right now I feel like a lot of
the things that people probably think
they want from a design book from you
are kind of covered on your website or
being touched on your website or I've
already been talked about by you in
episodes and I'm not coming for you
going to if I believe in the law of
abundance there's enough out there for
both of us but yeah that's what my site
is about like I I want to be able to
constantly be giving people information
about life and it's not just a design
website that's what I love the lifestyle
side it was I mean I opened it up and
it's just [ __ ] deviled eggs recipe
right there and matzo ball soup and I
was like I subscribe to this yes I want
to know everything so my a chef he's my
chef and my trainer and that sounds so
bougie every time I say it so I met him
in Kansas City when we were filming
there he was a trainer at the gym and
tan and Aunty and I all walked in and
we're like we'll take the cute gay one
actually not gay though Sara's amazing
but he's like you know in Kansas City
there aren't a lot of guys necessarily
that are like really great bodies and
take care of themselves and like super
well-groomed and I know he lived in
London was super articulate so we're
like oh yeah he's the gay one no but
he's not and so I just I fell in love
with him is like my bro and my friend
and we're travels so much and we're so
gone that it's you know it's not
ravished Anthony's body it sees obvious
I had a lot of time before
about that but the rest of us we don't
we're not as focused on it because we're
always traveling I need somebody who is
going to force me yeah to work out twice
a day and he's gonna cook for me and
cook healthy so I'm like you know what
do you want to move to LA and then I was
like you know we decided to launch the
site and I'm like I actually I want I
want to be like Oprah like that film
like I want to turn you into a brand and
like I want you because he wasn't just a
trainer here at the culinary school oh
cool so he's a chef and a trainer and
all into health I'm like you have
something to offer to people about
telling them how to achieve their
fitness goals in a realistic way and
food and so I'm like why don't you come
to LA be my trainer in my chef but then
also be a contributor to my website and
well you know I want to help him build
his career as well awesome he's your dr.
Phil his name's Zach and so your website
I mean it looks aesthetically so
pleasing it's really pretty and also
just like not overwhelming like it's
very easy to manage and so it's
basically anything lifestyle oriented
travel health and fitness food design
fashion and we do have like a shopping
area on it but you don't we don't sell
anything it's just like my favorite
things that I like it just links back to
whoever selling it you know so people
are was like oh what do you recommend
everybody recommend for that I don't
want to sell anything on my side yeah I
built my business on e-commerce and
e-commerce is hard you know I just like
I would just rather recommend my
favorite little shops my favorite things
to people when we first launched I think
the the only angry tweet that I kept
seeing over and over was people like um
Bobby has a $75 candle on his website um
yeah
thanks but no [ __ ] and I'm like okay
you know let's break this down [ __ ] you
know what if you don't want to spend $75
on a candle that's fine but you spent a
hundred bucks out at the bar last night
and you don't even remember it I spent
79 bucks on a candle that is gonna last
me for months and smells great and it's
gonna bring me [ __ ] joy so don't knock
my financial choices because you're
making the wrong one
it's all it's all about your priorities
in life if you want to go out I'm not
saying you spent $900 on drinks last
night
$12 candles options I'm putting out that
you should start a YouTube channel and
just responding to tweets like that I
would watch it religiously we've reached
the end of the podcast thank you so much
for being here before you go every guess
that makes time for us we give them a
personalized sports I thought that was a
big chunk of cheddar I think makes a
room really feel like home so this is
for you if you want to get your ASMR on
go for it I have a push-pull
relationship with a handsome we hear
your love for the Ben & Jerry's
Americone dream flavor and is it and it
is oh and it is valid you're an
intellectual indeed sir in bed in bed
there you go he know that Bobby where
can they find you so of course my
website Bobby Burke comm and that's B e
RK you can find me on the gram on
Twitter but easiest place is my website
cuz then that links back to the gram and
everything else and furniture is out
furniture is will actually be in stores
in China and Vietnam and Singapore and
the next like month we actually lost in
Asia first oh and then it'll be hitting
stores here in the States in September
October sweet yeah my wallpaper is out
now we just launched a new collection
with Tim paper all the great wallpaper
you see on all the episodes that's
removable self adhesive you can do
yourself it's all for my partners at M
paper really so tim paper designs calm
orton paper
by the way you my darling Sonam and then
my art is out and that's carried all
over the place as well
amazing thank you again for making time
so much and you know we'll keep fingers
crossed a nice peeled for that memoir
eventually can't wait thank you guys for
listening and watching this episode of
not too deep we'll see you guys next
time good 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep as the
creators of clean beauty Bare Minerals
is driven by a philosophy that makeup
and skin care should make your skin
better not just better looking and
that's why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients guess what they're all
minerals for bare minerals to be clean
without compromise means good for skin
formulas with proven performance to
upgrade to clean beauty products use
their foundation finder at their
minerals calm to find your perfect match
and first time customers will get 15%
off when you use the promo code not too
deep bare minerals the power of good not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]